December 9th 2015 this was a day that
many Dragon Ball fans throughout the
world rejoiced it marked a passing of
the torch from the old to the new this
was the day the dragon ball super
surpassed the movies and finally
produced new content that fans
universally had never seen before the
excitement within the community could be
felt and this proved to be the moment
the Dragon Ball super really took it up
a notch no longer shackled to the
monotony of retelling the movies it now
had the creative freedom to venture onto
roads untraveled and stories yet untold
now with a new sense of purpose and
vigor Dragon Ball super invited us to
the new universe six new characters
stakes and scenarios were presented
before us and while this is a list
consisting of the worst from this arc I
noticed when constructing this that
considerable level of improvement had
been made to the animation and the art
but I don't have about the good it's
time to criticize poor animation art and
direction I'm totally not mark and this
is the 10 worst and I made a moments of
Dragon Ball super universe 6 Ark number
10 Goku's mouth topping off the list is
the first of many indications that I
struggled to find bad moments to fill
this top 10 featured in the episode that
many fans wet their pants over
something's not quite right with Goku's
mouth here I was completely in fan mode
throughout the episode but this moment
while brief took me out of it for at
least a couple of seconds I'll concede
that it might just be me but something
about this mouth looks very mspaint II
not that there's anything wrong with
them as paint I just like to think that
Supes animation team might be a little
bit more sophisticated than that then
again no no no we're past that moving on
number 9 be in-between with screen time
before I start let me explain that I do
understand the meaning of in-between
frames and their importance really I do
it's to create a sense of flow from one
keyframe to the next on model accuracy
isn't as important as it is in the key
frames with in-betweens
therefore in-betweens can look like this
because they're only onscreen for a
fraction of a second
super isn't the only show that has these
either by the way every 2d animated
cartoon you've ever seen on TV has these
but this I can't let's light this
picture was on screen for far too long
for me not to notice that almost every
character is at least a little off
modeled not usually it just looks a
little sloppy this arc had some great
polish but this ultimately took me out
of the scene so far these are all easy
fix
the next however might take a little
more work than redrawing a single frame
number eight kaaba's Super Saiyan
transformation before I make an enemy of
everyone watching this video
understand that this isn't a bad scene
it's actually a pretty good scene both
in terms of animation and story but
similarly to the Vegeta vs. beerus
scuffle from episode 8 i expected more
from the scene in terms of
cinematography we've seen it in Dragon
Ball Z and super Tolle is capable of
executing gripping and visually stunning
transformations if they deem it
necessary or worthwhile and this
transformation began really well you
know it takes a lot of the Dragon Ball
transformation boxes monologue scream
close-up of the eyes ground crack you
know that kind of stuff but in my
opinion fell flat towards the climax
which really is the meat and potatoes of
the whole scene he suddenly changes
without so much as a different angle to
make it visually interesting Kaba
himself isn't the most visually exciting
looking character either and so I feel
that a tweak to the transformation angle
could really have helped make this more
aesthetically pleasing we've seen better
until we can definitely do better number
7
frost vs. Goku this is a great example
of a scene that did everything right
from a storytelling aspect but fell a
little short in the animation Department
this scene sets up Frost as he's
introduced to us as this Frieza
doppelganger that everyone loves the
choreography cinematography and
narrative direction for this fight was
thoroughly enjoyable however bad choices
in animation sloppy still work and
clunky movements stop this from being my
favorite episode of the arc overall it's
still the great episode heck it's even
an excellent one if you get past some of
the animation it's just a shame that
such a great episode didn't have great
animation to compliment it's sort of
like eating a delicious sloppy looking
burger on the side of the road the
presentation might not be great but the
taste and the experience you had eating
it was stand-up in short frost for me is
a delicious but awkward looking burger
number 6 Vegeta vs. Magette ax if the
last fight was a delicious burger this
scene is gone off and tasteless
perhaps I'm still recovering from the
barrage of blast attacks golden Frieza
had against Goku there was four by the
way but this scene in general wasn't
drawn low it's clear that to--a just
gave this blast sequence cut to the less
capable animators they don't value these
scenes and as a result they fall pretty
flat and these blast sequences are
consistently subpar throughout the show
by our one or two good ones it's a brief
cut but it was annoying enough for me to
mention it here again like others on
this list it's a minor gripe it's still
a great fight I had its fair share of
great moments too number five the
missing key frames an awkward stance
what I'm addressing this episode I'm
speaking about two instances in
particular those being that thing Goku
does here yeah that and this stands for
Chia decides to take four iteration of
the fight this weird flip goku takes is
more confusing than anything and
honestly looks like there's some frame
is missing from this cut it looks rushed
and generally sloppy it is a brief
moment though this on the other hand was
not brief this is more of a direction
mishap than a purely animated folly
vegeta having never taken this stance
prior decides to take it as his default
position for fighting hit it's not like
he's tired either it's clearly an
intentional stance taken by patita
i have no idea why he takes it but he's
doing it I just don't understand why
just seems like an awkward way to stand
and fight to me sort of really leave
yourself I don't know wide open number
four
Goku's running in weird arm alrighty
here we go this is the first cut of poor
animation on this list that lasts for a
discernable amount of time the
unfortunate thing is that this fight is
the first fight of the tournament first
time viewers of this arc should not use
this as a representation of what's to
come soldier through it because there
are some truly spectacular moments to be
had this scene is a doozy however
featuring poor pacing off model
characters and tweeting so if you
thought goku vs woody the pooh wasn't
awkward enough this particular cut of
the kamehameha kind of shows off this
deformed arm
whoever cleared this needs to have their
eyes checked drawings with no effort put
into them with lazy motion tweens don't
serve to do anything other than make me
want to tear my hair up i could ride in
the subject for hours and trust me
they'll be more but for now I think I'll
spare your ears and my sanity number 3
Vegeta Kaos frost this one is a little
iffy on one side you have an argument
that thinks of course Vegeta would
one-shot Frost he's in another league to
frost and doesn't need to exert himself
this early on in the tournament which I
guess makes sense other side whoever
believes that this was a lazy
representation of what could have been
another defining moment for Vegeta as a
character I find myself thinking the
latter unfortunately and
while I agree he is above frost the
animation given to this scene is a clear
indication that Thole didn't care about
this cut of the show at all I spoke
briefly before this video regarding the
weight of the characters punches this is
an example of a scene that did
everything to avoid drawing new frames
as much as possible it's all keyframes
and there are no in-betweens then
compared to the mangas interpretation of
these events it's hard to say that the
animes is better at least from an
entertainment perspective I think if
this clot was meticulously drawn and the
punch was given more oomph behind it
this scene could have been epic and if
you don't think a single punch can carry
that much significance in the scene just
look at this guy
number 2 Goku punches boat amo I can't
seem to escape from these weightless
flaccid limp punches that super seems to
be producing on the regular I don't
think is to anyone surprise that this
episode is so heavily featured on this
list either the Tommo
is a 2-dimensional boring character that
looks like we the Pooh on roids already
a subpar combination and then coupled
that with an animation sequence that
looks embarrassingly bad
it's no wonder has taken the spot in the
list as a 2d animator myself I am a firm
believer that CGI has its uses with
traditional 2d animation
Magette has lava spit is actually a
really good representation of that in
super this however looks flat lifeless
and lazy it took the hype and the
excitement for me out of the entire
episode and while this tournament is
spectacular it will always have this as
its opening boat number one the motion
tween dragon oh god do I have to this is
trash the entire arc was centered around
these super Dragon Balls and once they
are finally used barony the motion tween
dinosaur pops out now I'll give credit
where credit is due the overall design
of the character is awesome and the
sheer scale of the character is epic
but this honestly looks like a rough
draft of a storyboard to put things into
perspective
episodes 40 the episode that came before
this one was mostly animated by one guy
that one guy is Yoshitaka yeah she may
by the way the motion tween Dragon
episode had six weeks to be made for the
length of time given to this production
I would have expected better now I can
understand the difficulty with animating
a detailed complex character
but knowing that they shouldn't have
made it as ambitious as they did it's
all about time management here I would
have must preferred a 15 second long
sequence that was done excellently than
a two-minute one that looked awful
and I'm sure that I'm not alone in
thinking that whoo and we're done
I actually had a ton of fun watching
this arc again guys I slide from a
couple of questionable moments here and
there it's actually an incredibly solid
bunch of episodes you can really see the
rise in production quality between this
arc at the last and honestly I can't
wait to cover the best moments next week
if you guys don't want to miss the next
episode hit the subscribe button down
below
I've been totally not marked and this
has been the 10 worst animator bones I'm
Dragon Ball super is universe 6 arc
thank you so much for watching